You really care about them, don't you?
I think they're a bunch of
absolute losers.
But they're my losers.
This is the pre-boarding announcement
for Lusit Airways flight LLT154
to Marrakech.
We are now inviting
those classified as small children…
Come on. Where are you?
Please have your boarding pass
and identification ready. Thank you.
-ETA?
-Less than a minute.
-Has there been a handover?
-Negative.
Eyes on Dogs.
Why is he airside?
Intel said target was inbound.
He made visual contact, ma'am.
Reconfirm.
Second Desk requests we reconfirm visual.
You're looking for an Asian male,
20s, backpack, blue shirt, white tee.
Yes, confirmed,
and I have Dogs on standing by.
Shit.
Lost visual. Possible handover.
What does he mean "possible handover"?
-Cartwright, clarify.
-Did you catch anything on CCTV?
Negative, that's what you're there for.
Repeat, clarify.
He has a visual.
Did he see a handover or not?
Lost visual momentarily.
Repeat, possible handover.
-Come on. Get out of the way.
-Blocked by the cleaner.
Lusit Airways are pleased
to announce boarding
for flight LLT154 to Marrakech.
We would like to invite families
and those requiring assistance
-to come forward first.
-Move, move, move.
Please have your passports
and boarding card ready.
Okay, have full visual on target again,
but something has definitely gone
in or out of that backpack.
Tell him to hold.
Cartwright, hold your position.
Do not intercept.
-Target is on the move.
-We have eyes on target. Hold.
Ma'am?
Hold your position, Cartwright.
Hold your position. We are assessing.
Target is joining the queue to board.
Standing by.
Keep the channel clear, please.
Come on.
Second Desk says,
"Do not intercept."
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
-Push the button.
-Dogs are standing by, ma'am.
At least he's heading downstairs.
There's 300 bodies up there.
Yes, but he's headed to
a plane loaded with fuel.
First passengers are
on the tarmac, ma'am.
-Authorize.
-Apprehend suspect.
Dogs, go.
Move!
-Out of the way!
-Move!
-Down, down, down!
-What the fuck?
Get the fuck off me!
Disperse if you can. Keep calm.
-Get back!
-Get off me!
-What the fuck?
-Relax!
-What are you doing?
-No trigger.
-This is fucking harassment!
-No wires here.
-Clear.
-Bag.
-Get off! Get off me.
-Over.
Somebody film this! Fuck!
-Get off me! Nothing on me!
-Stop moving!
He's clean.
Repeat. Repeat!
There's no device, no weapon. Nothing.
-Ma'am?
-He has the wrong suspect,
or we have the wrong intel,
and we don't have the wrong intel.
-Ma'am, he reconfirmed visual.
-Reconfirm again.
Cartwright, confirm suspect description.
Asian male, 20s, backpack,
blue shirt, white tee.
I said, "white shirt, blue tee."
You--
No, no, no, no, you said--
you said, "blue shirt, white tee."
Webb.
Yeah.
Shit. Put it on the main screen.
White shirt, blue tee. Suspect is inbound.
Inbound, headed to immigration,
main terminal.
Stand Cartwright down. He's done.
Second Desk says
stand down, Cartwright.
Oh, shit.
-Stand him down.
-Cartwright, where are you going?
You tailed the wrong suspect.
You're stood down.
Get me CCTV on that escalator now.
-Should we have immigration hold him up?
-Not with a bomb on his back.
-Get SO15 on standby.
-Ma'am.
SO15, standby.
-He'll be through in two minutes.
-Duffy, where are your Dogs?
Still airside with Cartwright's suspect.
Jesus Christ!
If you can't get your guys there,
get SO15 on the ground now.
We got something behind immigration?
Excuse me.
Hey! Hey!
-How long?
-Three minutes.
He's through.
There.
He's headed to baggage reclaim.
Stay on him. I need eyes
at the end of that concourse.
-Yep. Coming up now.
-Head to the carousel.
He's headed to baggage reclaim.
Give me cameras
at the end of baggage reclaim.
I want eyes there.
Not a Dog in sight.
Duffy, those are your guys?
No. No, ma'am. They're en route.
Duffy, surely we've got
transport police on that concourse.
Waiting. Inbound, two minutes.
Thank you!
He's not waiting for luggage.
What? He's walking straight out.
Get out of the way! Move!
Move, move, move, move!
Sorry.
I'm service, I'm service.
I'm service! Move now!
-I need an image. Why is it dark in there?
-There's no cameras in there, ma'am.
-I want eyes now!
-Confirm with Stansted.
Dogs, intercept!
Suspect's now landside. Where are you?
-There.
-He swapped backpacks.
That's the handover.
Smash the glass.
This is an emergency. Please evacuate.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please evacuate the terminal!
Evacuate the terminal all the way…
-…this exit. This exit.
-Work out the safe areas.
Keep them safe. Don't let anyone pass.
This way please. Ladies and gentlemen,
this way. Quick as you can.
Move, move, move, move!
Move!
Move! Aside!
Move! Out of the way! Now!
He's headed for the Stansted Express.
Get out of the way!
Move! Get to the side.
Come on!
Get it cleared. Full evacuation.
Evacuate the entire train station.
I want any trains
coming into Stansted halted.
Any trains that are inbound imminently,
I need to know about it.
Move, move, move!
-Move, move, move, move, move!
-This way!
Keep moving, guys. Come on.
Place is closed! Stop! Stop!
What are you doing?
Stop! No! Step away now!
Step away! Don't do it!
No?
Yeah? Great!
Standish.
-Are you all in?
-All except River and Sid.
Yeah, well,
the last one in can clean my lav.
I thought spooks were
supposed to be stealthy.
Another day dawns on MI-Fucking Useless.
Morning, Max.
The usual, Mr. Hobden?
Yes, Max. The usual.
His name isn't Max.
Well, it says "Max"
on the front of the shop.
Yeah, but I heard the staff
call him Theo, short for Theodosios.
I'll stick with "Max." Shorter.
There you go.
Thank you, Max.
What are you looking for?
A reason not to blow my brains out.
He hasn't told me yet
what I'm looking for.
Dumping the rubbish this side of the room.
Do you think Sid will find this
as amusing as you do?
-Hello, Catherine.
-Morning.
Morning.
Bradford driving license applications,
addresses, council tax records.
Cross-check.
Well, these are from 2005.
The lending list
from Luton libraries in the last year.
At least yours is topical.
Flag any borrowing
that suggests money laundering.
Really?
Someone looking that up in the library
probably doesn't have
that much money to launder.
Parking tickets from the Euston area.
From the '90s?
No stone unturned, eh?
Oh, Catherine!
Catherine, before you go,
these two stick-in-the-muds
are giving my idea of a pub quiz team
a big thumbs down.
Actually, I gave it a fat middle finger.
Come on, guys! What about team spirit?
Catherine?
No.
-"No," as in "Ask me later," or no--
-As in, "no."
Tough nut to crack, that Catherine,
but I'll get there.
-Forget it. She never lightens up.
-Would you?
If I was Lamb's lackey, no.
No, I meant what happened before.
Before she came here.
Yeah, well, I wish Lamb
would go that way.
Is today the day you finally give me
something remotely challenging?
Flight inquiries to Syria
from the previous decade.
No, it isn't.
Well, I'll set up an algorithm for that
and treat the remaining nine hours
of the day as my own time.
Jed? Transport police are asking
if you can stop scaring people away
from that bus stop.
-They could be watching us.
-Or they could be waiting for a bus.
Also, Lamb says there's a new hire
-at the Chinese down--
-Oh, fuck me!
-And he'd like--
-I know, I know.
Interview and background.
And if he happens to be undocumented, it's
five free meals to look the other way.
Man.
No, I've been keeping me eyes
on the water.
I'm just waiting for a fin to surface,
but I need you to guarantee me
2,000 words once it breaks.
It's like your Watergate.
You know what?
I can't tell you now because it--
Sorry, the reason I interrupted before
is because I spent a year studying
in Greece and the name caught my ear.
Was a great country
a couple of thousand years ago.
Yeah.
And I'm interrupting now because
I was hoping I could borrow your Times.
-Fine.
-Thank you.
Oh, what--
-Oh, my God. I am so--
-Oh, shit.
-I am so sorry. I'm so sorry. Sorry.
Can I please have some towels? Okay.
Can I just have some serviettes?
No, I need more serviettes.
-God, I'm so--
-Here. Here.
Yeah, napkins. Can we get some more?
Thank you.
Max, this is not enough. Have you--
Have you got any more serviettes?
-Max, pass me that.
-Take this. Take this.
-Just leave it. Excuse me.
-I'm so, so clumsy.
-Would you leave it?
-No, I feel so bad. Is your laptop okay?
It's okay. Let me clean it up now.
Fuck!
Fucking…
You thumped?
Did you find anything?
I don't know what I'm looking for.
Yeah, the remnants
of a once-promising career.
Are we actually acting on any intel,
or are we just fishing?
Yeah, but now,
you don't get to ask questions.
That's for spies who haven't shat the bed.
So, what did you find? Any old notebooks?
The cardboard backing of one,
but no pages.
Evidence of drug use?
Empty box of paracetamol, yeah.
Empty booze bottles?
In his recycling bin, I imagine.
Oh, Christ.
Is it me, or did all the fun
go out of everything around 1979?
Are we looking for something,
or are we just wanting him to know
that we are looking at him?
What's all this "we"? There is no "we."
There's just me telling you what to do.
Okay. Do you want to tell me
to put him under surveillance?
Who?
Hobden.
You would be doing the surveillance?
Yeah.
-You?
-Yeah.
Well--
That's a-- Well,
that's an interesting proposition,
considering the last time
you were given any sort of responsibility,
a load of innocent people
got blown to bits.
And there it is.
Well, I'm sorry you find it so tiresome,
Cartwright,
but it's not the social faux pas
you seem to think it was.
You didn't break wind
during someone's wedding vows.
What was it? 149 dead, 212 injured,
Three million in damages,
half a billion in lost revenue--
It was a training exercise.
If a pilot crashes a simulator,
he doesn't then brush it off and go,
"Well, I'm sorry.
It was a fucking exercise,"
and then expect to be
put behind the wheel of a 747.
-It's not the same thing.
-No, it's worse, you tit.
-You're gonna do this every day then?
-If I didn't hate the sight of you,
I'd come to your home
and do it at the weekends too.
I am surrounded by fuckups
in this building,
but you are the gold standard of fuckups.
By all rights, you shouldn't even be here.
You should've skipped this purgatory
and gone straight to hell.
Melted you down for glue.
But you avoided that
because your name is Cartwright.
So when you wonder why I have you
going through the rubbish
of a disgraced right-wing journo,
wonder no more.
It's because I don't like you.
And I want you to quit.